known for her signature white headscarf
de bonafini became the symbol of a
mother's struggle after The
Disappearance of her two sons
I always say that Lions grew inside me
when they took my children wearing the
scarf makes me feel taller more composed
it feels like the Embrace of my children
in the late 1970s she founded the
mothers of the plaza de Mayo along with
other women to demand the return of
their children taken by Security Forces
they're worn nappies on their heads
later swapping them for white scarves an
emblem of their movement
de bonafini worked tirelessly to expose
the fate of the estimated 30 000
argentinians who disappeared during the
so-called dirty war in the 70s and 80s
although her own Sons were never found
she continued her campaign even after
the dictatorship ended becoming one of
Argentina's most passionate and
outspoken rights activists
even today more than 40 years after
their first March the mothers of the
plaza de Mayo remains a powerful force
holding Gatherings to continue de
bonifini's Legacy
she taught us not to lower our heads and
not to cry in front of the enemy to be
seen as strong even if the tears came we
had to go out into the street with a
heads held high proud of the children we
had our kidnapped children
on hearing the news of her death
President Alberto Fernandez declared
three days of national mourning calling
her a tireless fighter de bonafini may
have divided Argentina in her later
years with her controversial comments
and political affiliations but the pain
of her early days unified a nation and
turned her into a figure of struggle
driven by a need for answers and justice